yeah it's going to be exciting it's also
going to be a lot of material and yeah
imagine you're building Gmail and you
know we both work on Google+ so this is
as much as a mind game for us than it is
for everybody here except this guy who's
actually working on Gmail and so most of
you guys probably know Gmail it looks
somehow like you know this it's fake
right so there's megabytes of JavaScript
and you would think that you probably
don't eat all of it right away
right so initially you might draw
something and then you know the user
does something need a little more code
so it you know that's that's kind of how
it looks and you know we can probably
agree on that
downloading lots of JavaScript is you
know it can be really slow and that
compilation of JavaScript is also
something that may be slow so to follow
along this is our example app you know
it's Gmail it has an inbox and has a
compose you and kind of our assumption
is that not everybody always composed
emails so it's kind of wasteful to load
all the code you need to compose emails
right and then we make this completely
arbitrary made-up dependency tree that
has you know this thing that we call
inbox app at the top and then it's like
an inbox model and an inbox view and the
inbox model depends on the Ajax thing
and the thread Porter and the URL module
is a dependency of the Ajax module can
you see that yeah and then it's like the
template renderer and the text Kade and
it's yeah doesn't really matter it's all
just things we made up it's a dependency
tree you know you have modules to kind
of need other stuff and when you act the
compose app you get you know these two
other things like the email sender and
the compose view and the compost view
also depends on the same thing the
template renderer and the text get thing
and the email sender needs Ajax so
there's you know there's some overlap
and the dependencies between those two
apps so and we talk about JavaScript
loading so let's imagine we're building
our app with require.js
now requirejs is two ways to load
JavaScript that's the HR
kind of built in and this is the first
one that you would used in development
and it's recursive downloading so you
say you know your abscess I want the
inbox app so it figures you know there's
these two things that I know I need
because they're like defined to be my
dependencies it downloads them then they
go and say yeah I actually do need a
couple more modules and download them
and then a Jake says yeah I also need
the URL module and there's another step
so loading JavaScript like this is
really really bad its overall hhb
requests and there's a four step
waterfall so assuming you have like a
round-trip time of like 100 milliseconds
it takes 400 seconds just to do these
like trivial module loading which is bad
let's look at the incremental load so
now let's say like we want to load the
compost app and that's actually really
easy in with AMD say like you load it
and then it figures out okay then email
sender and the compose for you and then
you have all this other dependencies but
they're already there so it doesn't
download them anymore
so it's a little bit better in the
incremental load so it's three HTTP
requests and still two-step waterfall
really really bad so what can you do
require.js has this you know thing where
I say you compile it all into one big
file you know you have your entry module
and they figured out all dependencies
makes it one thing right and you deliver
that in production and that's actually a
very very very good way to deliver
JavaScript that's totally what you want
to do it's super super efficient for
small to medium and we don't really know
where the cutoff is apps so but it
doesn't scale there's some point where
you know and it certainly reached if you
are at a megabyte where you do not want
to do this anymore because it's just too
big right and so we figured like how can
we fix this yeah so we're talking about
JavaScript serving and the Gmail team
actually came up with the initial
implementation of a solution to this
which is basically to teach the server a
couple of things about how to serve
javascript the themes here are first of
all teach the server the dependency tree
the server can know it the client does
not need to figure it out and by
teaching the server the dependency tree
we can get rid of the recursive sort of
downloading from a client perspective we
want it to be as simple as possible just
ask for what you need
actly when you need it and then we pair
this with closure compiler for
minification and various other benefits
that I will go on to talk about so the
initial request ends up looking
something like this which is kind of
like the one big file that melted was
talking about which is to say you asked
for inbox app and then the URL jebaited
just directs the server give me all the
dependencies that inbox app also has the
server resolves this concatenates theme
spits it out out of the socket browser
loads it up well and good
so for incremental loading our initial
implementation was basically just to
have that initial boot payload the
server emitted the module graph to the
client and says hey look in addition to
inbox app and all of its contents here's
the module graph for the entire
application the module graph is a lot
smaller than the code of course and so
the client is able to construct a URL
for the incremental load for compose app
by simply just traversing the module
graph and asking for the individual
library modules without other
dependencies so that's our first cut now
the client calculates it all of our
requests are still 1 HP 1hp or requests
and things are still are fairly
efficient but there's downsides in
particular the client needs to download
the whole dependency tree that can get a
little bit large more importantly the
client code required for incremental
loading needs to be able to parse it
keep track of all various data
structures the client ends up getting a
lot more complicated so we came up with
this idea actually John did but I talked
about it- loading which is super crazy
easy and awesome
so the first request is the exact same
with the other module you say you know I
want inbox app and the server goes and
fetched all the dependencies give it to
you and on the incremental load the
super-crazy inside comes you tell the
server I want compose app but I already
have inbox app and then the server is
really smart and can tell you know
figures are dependencies of those two
things subtract them that's why we call
it negative loading and only gives you
the Delta that you really need so let's
look at a couple example URLs we
invented this you know slash a slash and
then plus inbox apps that's the first
request
on the second request say we want to
allow composer we say compose app -
inbox app and the third request where we
invented cent app we say okay we want
cent app we already have inbox app and
compose app so the nice thing is that
this makes this client super super
stupid simple so constructing like a URL
just says you know whatever module you
want and then you join all the requested
module you have and immediately push the
module you request it onto the requested
thing and the next request just you know
keeps on adding goes so that's that
that's that's your JavaScript loader
it's the one is like two lines of code
which is I think super awesome but
there's one problem that there's no
there's a conserved concurrency thing
right and so each one of these requests
needs to execute right after the other
so if you're adding adding them
dynamically to the Dom browser can
download them in any particular order
execute them in whatever order shows up
obviously that not only is suboptimal in
terms of performance you'd like to be
able to download as much as you can at
the same time in cases where it makes
sense it also adds complexity to the
loader and that you need to detect
somehow and there's various mechanisms
to do this when each one of the FEM each
one of these payloads has completed so
that it can kick off the next request
thereby serializing them together so we
try we wanted to do a little bit better
and so we introduced something called
callback loading it's my name I take
responsibility for it if you have if you
know anybody who's good at marketing and
has a better name for it please tell me
because it's not the most fantastic name
but basically you can think of it as
Jason p4 for JavaScript code so the
loader is responsible for setting up a
loading function that is that wraps the
JavaScript that comes in now in the
naive implementation you can basically
just stringify all your j s eval it in
in the loader and the loader callback
needs to just be smart enough to know I
cannot execute until everything that was
supposed to have executed before me is
complete so here's an example of some of
a couple of the URLs sort of translated
a little bit of the incremental loads so
we want to compose app - the inbox app
and we and basically just say hey look
server I've set up a callback called
load underbar one you could also
namespace it too
pollute that global namespace less that
is responsible for actually executing
the code that comes back from the server
likewise loading send app a little bit
later I'm indicating to subtract inbox
app and compose app load to function is
responsible for doing this so what does
the code look like this is not the
actual code I wrote this basically just
to demonstrate that it can be written
tersely I'll describe kind of what it
does and you can implant it much more
clearly but the idea is that the loader
sets up the load underbar some index
method which in turn sets up any exact
method that is responsible for executing
the jeaious that it that it picked up if
a payload comes in out of order then
what it for instance if payload one
comes in after payload zero it just says
hey look I'm not ready yet
payload zero is not complete yet or to
you know before one but when one comes
in later it executes its own payload
saying hey I'm ready I'm ready now all
of my dependencies are executed and I'm
going to keep forward executing
everything else that's already been set
up and the executor deletes itself after
executing to make sure that you don't
dual execute so the example I just kind
of walk through is like this load 1
followed by load zero you define the
load 1 in the function R 0 then 1 and
then the last loaded bit says well 1 is
the last one that's kind of like
outstanding load 1 shows up and says hey
look zero hasn't executed yet I'm just
going to kind of put a placeholder there
saying that you know call this function
whenever you want to execute you see
where this is going load zero comes in
gets the code says alright I'm ready
it executes itself and it executes load
one thereby achieving concurrency so the
one one issue with this and the native
implementation is that we get code as in
a string representation via eval that's
not a huge problem there's very you know
that there's pros and cons to this but
among some of the issues that we ran
into particularly in the Google+ world
is that we really wanted to make sure
not to pollute the global namespace so
we tried to kill two birds with one
stone avoiding eval all at the same time
not polluting global name space with a
closure compiler passed that multi wrote
called reefs cope global symbol
yeah the way this works is it's actually
super simple so imagine you have a
global symbol like var x equals zero and
what we do is we find all those global
symbols and then we put them in a
namespace in this case it's called NS in
our real implementation we call it
underscore because underscores are
awesome and then it finds all the
references to this symbol and and always
says n I start X and s dot plot and what
this allows you is to wrap your response
in a closure and you inject the
namespace NS from into this closure and
the nice thing about this is you can do
incremental loads so you get more
JavaScript and if you wrapped up in
closures it's not visible anymore so it
doesn't work if you have if you're in an
incremental loading scenario but with
this basically you get the same like you
get the this thing we call a synthetic
namespace that's accessible to all the
payloads that are being loaded
individually and only if you if you say
window dot something explicitly it goes
into the actual global scope you know
we're working on the plus one team and
we never ever want to put stuff in like
namespaces of people if they embed plus
one so this is like super important for
us it might not be super important for
everybody yeah and the benefits are that
you get super hyper guaranteed you know
execution order but you can load
everything apparel and you know it's
only executed when you need it and
there's no change of any symbol
conflicts whatsoever we just decide
don't have to like dwell too much in
this way we then realized if we put var
window equals this at the beginning and
then go and find all the external
symbols from the environment and prefix
them with window dot that's an identity
transformation so the program still
works everybody with me
so what's awesome is you can now go and
apply this to be a different iframe and
we use this to essentially take this
code that's being rewritten and apply to
different iframes so you can
if you happen to have more than one
iframe and because your Remi and you
know you don't want to like compile or
like code more than once you can do
ding-ding-ding and apply to all them
kind of cool potential problems oh do
you want to know it I'll take it I'll
take this one and so what a couple of
the potential problems with this
approach just to kind of walk through
some of the implications is for one if
you have an independent incremental
requests the client doesn't know
anything about this and the default
loader basically just says all right
well one one needs to load before to
vice versa so but if you load solo one +
solo2 in this toy dependency graph here
in theory they could actually they get
it execute at the same time so how could
we ameliorate this we haven't actually
implemented this but just kind of what I
wanted to walk through it basically the
server could inject the dependencies
that it used among among what it what
the request indicated to subtract what
it was already requested the client is
smart enough to know what already is
loaded so if there's no overlap based
execute the payload right away another
potential problem is wasteful increment
incremental requests if you have as here
top depends on middle depends on bottom
you start with a request for top and
then you say now I want middle one way
to implement this naively is just doing
a simple check if some symbol you know
in middle whatever but you don't want to
pepper your code with that too much so
basically you just do load middle and
then start using it what that would do
in the naive implementation is say well
load middle - top which basically just
emits a zero pay zero byte request that
executes the payload it still works but
there's no particular point to it a
similar optimization could be used for
this basically just to omit the true the
tree of dependency is for any given
request that comes in and we're kind of
look looking at some of these
optimizations right now so the question
is how can you guys build this so what
you basically need is this data
structure that represents your
dependency tree and your server needs it
so from this you built this kind of flat
dependency graph for you basically for
like inbox app you have this list of
things you need and for your you know
and and and so on and and then
you have this you know you basically
need all your modules in one file and
have that in memory and you just go you
know what does the Pennsy tree say and
then you have your server emit those
ding-ding-ding one by one so this is
basically what what serving looks like
so you know let's say you want the
requested module so you get their
requested modules then you have you know
what's already loaded that's the - part
you get them and in order to find the
ones you want to serve you calculate the
intersection between those two lists and
you know recruit remove that from the
thing from the new list and then you
search them that's all so that's you
know also on the server side quite a
quite a simple implementation one thing
so we are using closure compiler which
is you know one of the more popular
minifiers and closure compiler has one
little-known feature is that it's
actually you know first-class support
for modules and so normal magnifier is
you put like n like a lot of JavaScript
files in and you get one file out close
to compile like heading minify lots of
files and then give you the files back
but they're consistently minified so it
renamed my like a global function to a
and then they've made it like they named
a and all of them so but you still have
the files and that's important for the
serving model because then you can come
you can defer the actual concatenation
to runtime which is you know basically
what we not want and yeah so it's
uncouples minification from
concatenation which when you think about
it it's kind of a neat way and just
because you know nobody used to do this
I think nobody had the idea to go with
this and so one thing you know I did in
my free time it's not super robust but
it works
it's a edit both support for common J's
modules and for AMD modules to closure
compiler so it can go and say you know
this is my module and then it finds all
the dependencies builds the module graph
and like does all this computation and
if you're interested it does it in a way
that it's trying to be super efficient
and it actually looks similar to the
generated code that you saw this morning
from the folks from typescript how they
represent module
so essentially every time you do a
require it actually just stupidly
replaces it with a name of the variable
and it guesses the name of the variable
from the module name and then when you
actually define the module exports equal
becomes an assignment to that variable
name so exports gets also replaced with
a variable name and then you can just
cognate it the program it works without
any like so the whole notion of modules
goes away which is kind of freaky but
kind of works and I think it's worth
noting actually that our hope anyway
with this is to set up a protocol
whereby nej s can be served in this way
so long as you can define some notion of
a named library all the compiler passes
work on arbitrary J s and whatnot but we
do want it to be as flexible as possible
with and is sort of convenient and
understandable as possible to people who
already are using require J's common J's
and so on so what's the current study so
we use this as Google we're from the
social widget team what means like +1
and some more and so we use this the the
G+ you know proper side they still use
this other version that we talked about
that where the client side does the
calculation so you get still 1hb
requests but more complicated and we
hope to roll out a lot some more
properties soon actually so our current
server side implementation is in in Java
we're currently reporting to see bus
dressed to save some electricity but you
know both not our favorite programming
language so this slide essentially def
bank I was hoping for
thunderstorms but there is a github.com
slash Google slash module server which
is an open source implementation of all
everything we talked about today
very very written in node.js so you can
use it in your own project it's you know
super duper alpha untested because we
kind of wrote it not for ourselves but
you you guys sorry feel free to make it
actually using all the other projects
yeah so it's you know it's not that it's
not battle tested so it has unit tests
basically that's what it says it was
but it's designed to be fast you still
get this like only mem copy runtime
there's full source map support so while
you have the single file serving you in
the like in your dev tools it all looks
awesome it includes a client lower lip
which is actually based on lap GS
because there was two you know a lap
Jace's get if I JavaScript loader
because I was like you know I didn't
want to write a JavaScript loader this
is a module loader so it's a module
lower later layered on a JavaScript
loader and it also reps closure compiler
so it's super easy to use because
closure compiler can be kind of like
weird with all those command line
parameters yeah let's let's take a look
github so i'm meltus doing this I will
admit that some of the potential
downsides and enhancements and whatnot
we put in this deck under the hope that
somebody here is possibly interested in
say helping to implement it with us so
feel free to contact us if anybody is
interested in contributing to the
project I love - I'm just super pumped
about using this in production Google -
maybe not I don't know I think I would
so yeah this is the the project there's
basically so there's this file called
demo server j/s so because I know like
people are using like Express or they
hate Express or they using something
else you know this is something you need
to integrate into your serving stacks so
this demo server is a no dependency
thing written a note that source stuff
but it you know might not be suitable
for whatever middle-way you're using so
you you write your you know maybe
somebody writes an Express integration
that reps this module server j/s and the
module graph thing yeah let's let's uh
you know I don't have the best demo in
the world this is the demo you can load
more code well as you can see you know
these are the there's like the ugly URLs
for the incremental loads but you know
because with source Maps you
you know they actual I think we can do
this much better
you know these are the actual you know
standard common J's modules and so it
should even be nice in developing but
you can also like just use AMD
require.js and development and then you
know when when you go to oh you know
I wrote a megabyte of JavaScript
eventually you port to this for
production and I think that's it thank
you we did want to mention that you know
this was kinda lot of input will be at
the google boost in the next break but
now we are open for questions so closure
already provides module loader along
with the modules ation in the
compilation as as you stressed it so is
the advantage here that you can change
the which dependencies you pull in at
run time rather than statically
beforehand so I mean dependency and that
was static but at runtime you say you
know
so you basically say this is my whole
app universe but you start with a subset
and then at runtime you say now I load
this other subset of my application and
you know that's the incremental thing
also so the closure library which is
nothing to do with the closure compiler
has some kind of a module loader in it
but it's not meant to be used outside
development except when you compile into
one big file which is awesome you know
but this was kind of a point that you
don't have to and we've been working
with them to possibly integrate some of
these techniques into that lawyer as
well okay
Hey expect you to have some long
expiration time on the for caching on
those goods so how do you change the URL
when you release or patch out new
versions so there's a couple of
different scheme schemes for doing that
the way that we happen to have implanted
it within Plus is basically we send
along a URL template with every request
in that template basically has encoded
within it the version which is basically
just a hash of all the content of the
entire set of code so it's a template
because you the modules that you want to
load are what's template template it in
so from there but basically we just push
a new template and you get a new code
one more
one more question separate topic how
much does how much size impact does the
global name spacing add so we when we
took a look at this
we noticed so it's roughly 2 or maybe 3
bytes per property access like on we use
underbar it can be an S dot or something
of that nature so our increase was
something on the order of like 3 to 4
percent but at G zips to essentially
zero because the the underbar dot is
repeated so many times and the same is
true actually for the window dot prefix
you just get window dot everywhere so
gzip stole most nothing
okay that's but also tanika's there is a
performance problem if any v8 people are
listening maybe they can fix it because
we add like all these properties on this
one thing we always said so we don't
currently use this and if you know you
don't need it and so where were you
performance critical we don't need it we
don't use it but you could think about
using erase instead and that'll be super
fast too but a bit bigger okay all right
thank you guys very much